all right let's go to our next caller
our next caller is from the oh I don't
know how about the 304 area code caller
from 304 what's your name and where are
you calling from today I'm Gary and I'm
Ralston West Virginia great what's on
your mind today I was wondering what
your opinions of just trying to a little
bit later making the main focus
whispered to me about primary dimensions
and my concern is we have three
congressional controlled by Republican
and what other Senate seat is controlled
by Republicans should we be focusing on
those first yeah we were sort of in a
way talking about this with a previous
caller yeah there you know I I think
that a lot of times there's false
dichotomies presented in terms of what
we can focus on this but shouldn't we be
focusing on that and then usually the
way it goes as someone shows up and says
well I support an all-of-the-above
approach and we should be focusing on
everything but you do sort of have
limited resources and I think that what
what makes sense to consider with
limited resources and multiple races
that you could go after is is there one
race that is sort of lower hanging fruit
in the sense that it is a more winnable
race and I think that it's fair to
consider that Pat it would be great to
just say focus on all of it but there
are limited resources there are limited
dollars that are going to be available
to campaigns and we should consider
what's most winnable to some degree yeah
and also of course Senate seats are more
powerful than House seats because
they're just far less senators and you
know joe Manchin I think is a target
that we should go after because he's
kind of a wool in sheep's clothing yet
yes he is a Democrat but he votes with
Republicans so often yeah and he's
willing to give this apologist
perspective when it comes to Donald
Trump I'm mixed on that I generally am
sympathetic to what you're saying Pat
but at the same time you know earlier
this week he was asked to comment about
the the Comey memo and Trump Russia and
whatnot he seems to be playing it the
way he should be playing it with regard
to that investigation he doesn't seem to
be sort of taking a Republican approach
from what I've seen so maybe it does
make sense to target some red house
seats in West Virginia right I know but
also you have people like Susan Collins
bob corker John McCain all
looking senators who are also
questioning Trump at this moment yeah
yeah there's no shortage of that all
right so thanks thanks for the call I
mean there may not be a great answer but
hopefully that sort of approximates some
of what you were talking about all right
thank you all right thank you really
really appreciate the call